there are more mixed signals about what
russia is planning in ukraine moscow
claims it's pulling back some of its
forces from the ukrainian border but
nato and ukraine say they've seen no
signs of de-escalation they say there is
evidence the kremlin is adding troops as
jackson proskow explains the white house
is warning of a fresh attempt by russia
to create a pretext for an invasion
ukraine had declared this a day of
national unity the day the west had
warned russia might mount a large scale
of salt
but the only military action came in the
form of drills overseen by president
vladimir zelinsky ukrainians practiced
firing american-made anti-tank missiles
and bombing runs meant to take out a
column of invading russian tanks
we are not afraid of any people of any
enemy zolensky told the troops
moscow may have blinked for now at least
that's the claim
russia released video of some of its
troops and tanks returning to bases
few believe it's any kind of meaningful
de-escalation we continue to see
critical units moving toward the border
not away from the border nato defense
ministers remain deeply cautious
unwilling to trust russia until they can
verify its intent we look forward to
seeing
evidence of the withdrawal of troops on
russia's part but we need to prepare for
any eventuality
what russia does is more important than
what it says and russian media report
the country is suddenly investigating
what it claims are mass graves in the
disputed pro-russian region of donbass
where vladimir putin this week claimed
genocide is taking place
the white house warns it could all be an
excuse for putin to launch military
action there could be a range of
false flags and pretext that we would
expect would
precede
an invasion though the kremlin denies
responsibility ukraine is already
navigating one of the worst cyber
attacks in its history it took down
banks and government websites
it has not ended the resolve of the
ukrainian people to defend their country
tonight the warnings about an imminent
attack are growing stronger the u.s
believes russian troops may have moved
into fighting position and the uk warns
the russian military is building field
hospitals to treat wounded soldiers
donna
all right jackson thank you nato
countries in eastern europe are on high
alert poland shares a border with
ukraine and is a nato member and that's
where thousands of soldiers have been
sent our europe bureau chief crystal
gamansing is in southeast poland tonight
crystal
donna american soldiers here in
southeastern poland are hard to miss
throughout the day we saw convoys of
military vehicles headed to a makeshift
base about an hour away and chinook
helicopters overhead
there's urgency as americans move into
poland strengthening nato's eastern
flank
thousands of personnel some just arrived
preparing for a russian escalation or
invasion there's been a flurry of
activity here at this staging area we
have seen numerous humvees coming and
going at least a half a dozen raf semi
coaches taking soldiers to and from this
location both american soldiers we've
seen as well as polish soldiers
they're here to ensure the safety of
those living in this and other nato
countries but their presence underscores
the potential for war this is so
very frightening
and
kind of sad so
i'm a little afraid about this
from this part of southeastern poland
it's only about an hour's drive to the
ukrainian border between neighbors the
greatest needs are known urgent medical
care and housing for refugees will need
to be prioritized if there's an invasion
says ukraine's ambassador they don't
know how many they can
adopt
the ukrainians
but
i'm trying we are trying to convince
them that we will do
our best
not to
create a situation
when ukrainians
will have to flee the country
fighting in the donbass region has been
going on for years but when war first
broke out between ukraine and
pro-russian separatists in 2014 hundreds
sought safety in poland some analysts
fear the territory could be used as a
bargaining chip along with ukraine's
desire to join nato it can seem to some
of our western allies
to be
an appropriate compromise
in order to stop
the worst possible scenario like real
war those issues are critical to
ukraine's future and to many
too big to abandon
donna
all right crystal gomezing in poland
tonight thanks